what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like amidst all of these
changes that Marvel Studios is seemingly
going through right now with some delays
in Phase 5 and phase six with new
special presentations being announced
with the Fantastic Four rumors going
crazy and Marvel Studios cracking down
on who exactly they want to be their
first family to Executive Vice President
Victoria Alonso no longer being with
Marvel Studios it looks like Marvel is
making some big moves and one of those
moves might be for Secret Wars as well
now we have talked about a lot of
changes happening to the MCU recently
and I know a lot of fans have sometimes
taken this as a bad thing however the
Marvel Studios change that they could
possibly be making to Secret Wars is
good it's going to mean a lot for Secret
Wars and also the Kang Dynasty as well
and everything that is going to happen
in between those films reports and
rumors have told us that what's going to
happen between the King Dynasty and
Secret Wars is actually going to be
pretty great and is kind of just going
to be a part of the same story that
these Avenger stories are going to be
telling and if Marvel Studios does this
the right way this could be an even
bigger event than Avengers Infinity war
and Avengers end game now both of those
movies Infinity war and in-game were a
part 1 and a part two in fact when they
originally announced them they simply
said Avengers Infinity War part 1 and
then they listed part two as well it
wasn't until later that they revealed
that Avengers endgame was indeed the
title of Avengers 4 and that was also
after they told us that it wasn't the
title but of course it was and also
granted I would argue that Marvel
Studios did not plan on releasing the
titles for the next two Avengers films
the Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars however
right before they revealed Phase 5 and
some of phase six the titles were
actually leaked a day before so Marvel
Studios revealed those titles for phase
six I'm not sure they would have
otherwise because what's interesting is
Marvel Studios kept phase six pretty
secretive except for the Fantastic Four
which we already knew was coming but
perhaps there was a good reason of why
they were keeping phase six such a
secret and one of those reasons could be
because of Secret Wars it looks like
Marvel Studios actually plans for Secret
Wars to be a two-part film that's right
according to another report Avengers
Secret Wars could be a part one and a
part two film and I have talked about
this before when the first rumors
started going around but now I think
this is going to happen more than ever
and I think there's an extremely good
reason as to why this is going to happen
that just makes sense and I think fans
are going to think that this is indeed
going to be for the better now if you've
been watching the channel for a bit or
just keeping up with Marvel Cinematic
Universe news on your own you know that
Marvel Studios right now is focusing on
quality over quantity and you know that
we are getting some delays in Phase 5
and phase six for that specific reason
so they can have more time to work on
individual projects not be rushed and
put more essentially care into them this
is confirmed by Marvel Studios president
Kevin feige and the Disney CEO Bob Iger
so they're going to do fewer projects a
year and I think this also leads to
Secret Wars being a part one and a part
2 movie this is essentially going to
give us a three-part film Avengers the
King Dynasty Avenger Secret Wars part 1
and part two although the Kang Dynasty
is going to be very different than
Secret Wars based off of everything that
I've heard but the reason that Marvel
Studios is going to split Secret Wars
into two parts is so they can do it
right this is a movie that is supposed
to be bigger than Avengers endgame how
do you go bigger while you involve the
Multiverse that is Marvel studios's plan
but that doesn't mean you can execute it
right if you don't do the right things
and I personally think that making it a
two-part movie is doing the right thing
with all of the different universes that
exist in the Multiverse with all of the
different Heroes that exist out there
coming together the X-Men from other
universes from the foxy Universe the
Fantastic Four from other universes plus
not to mention the Avengers from other
universes and on top of that the Kings
from other universes all coming together
in one big movie well you can see how a
three-hour movie a three and a half hour
movie well that's not gonna cut it
you're gonna have to jam a whole lot
into one movie and really if they wanted
to do it right this would have to be
about a four hour movie which some
people in fact a lot of people complain
that they can't sit through a four hour
movie even if it's an Avengers film
three hours is really hard to sit
through for some people as well a lot of
people have to get up go use the
bathroom people want refills on their
popcorn on their drinks and they don't
want to get up so making a four to a
four and a half hour movie isn't really
ideal however what is ideal is splitting
up the movie into two different parts
that way you can have each movie be
about three hours long and you can take
your time with the story nothing has to
be rushed at all you don't have to cram
a bunch of scenes into one movie you
don't have to cut a bunch of scenes
because the movie is too long and you
can spend more time on character
development and I think that's actually
been kind of a problem that Marvel
Studios has had recently Ant-Man and the
WASP was a perfect example the movie was
too short I think the movie should have
been longer because in the end where the
quantum people were kind of starting a
revolution I didn't really have that
much of an emotional connection to them
because I feel like I didn't spend that
much time with them to really develop
that connection in the movie and I
talked with a lot of you all on Twitter
and on Instagram asking you the same
question a lot of you agreed I talked to
other YouTubers as well and a lot of
people agreed on this so splitting
Secret Wars into two different films
would make it to where they could really
do it right and that's what I think
everybody wants this movie or movies if
it's going to be split up into two
different parts needs to be done right
and this is a perfect way to do it now
speaking on whether it's going to be
really a two-part film or a three-part
film with King Dynasty like I mentioned
we've learned that the King Dynasty is
going to be quite different than Secret
Wars secret Wars truly is going to be a
multiversal film it will explore a bunch
of different universes a bunch of
different Heroes a bunch of different
teams like the X-Men Fantastic Four
Avengers it's a true Multiverse film
however the Kang Dynasty is not that the
Kang Dynasty is very much going to be
focused just on Earth and our Avengers
our new Avengers team whoever Marvel
Studios has planned to be on that roster
this is apparently how it's going to
work Kang is going to come for the Kang
Dynasty and it's kind of going to be
like Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
not story-wise not quality wise but just
the fact that there's only going to be
one Kang but the Multiverse and the
other kangs will be mentioned but the
movie will take place in the earth 616
Universe they're not going to Multiverse
travel a lot if any at all and they will
most likely lose to King the Conqueror
at the end of this film much like an
Avengers Infinity War The Avengers lose
to Thanos this will then set up the
events that happen between the King
Dynasty and Secret Wars which is going
to be about the Multiverse from what
we've heard our heroes between the King
Dynasty and Secret Wars will then start
traveling the Multiverse searching for
other Heroes to take on Kang and his
variants then in Avengers Secret Wars
they're going to show us the perspective
from the other universes so this could
be them showing us one Universe where a
different Fantastic Four team is
fighting king or in Another Universe a
completely different Avengers team is
fighting King then in Another Universe
we have the X-Men who are fighting King
it could be the first Class X-Men and
then in Another Universe we could have
the fox X-Men fighting a different
version of King so basically it is what
we want a giant multiversal battle for
the fate of the entire Multiverse until
eventually I'm assuming they're all
going to come together in one universe
and take on either what's called Prime
Kang or the Council of Kings which you
know is going to be an insane fight
which is why I'm okay with Marvel
Studios making secret Wars into a part
one and a part 2 with all of that
happening it needs to have time
ironically enough because time is really
nothing to Kang he controls it but to do
this movie right it needs to not be
rushed it needs to have a lot of scenes
not be cut for the sake of trying to
make it a three-hour movie so I think
part one and part two for this is a good
idea but hey let us know what you think
about this in the comments down below
you like this or do you not like it let
us know down below and please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all of the
latest MCU news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
hi